kenan difíceis para a tarefa
já não bastava na batata tomate difícil
tirar a gente tem que ajudar da rocinha
à favela
[Música]
sei que a minha mão
ela só tem tudo para dar certo mas já
estamos em face da ii etapa do plano de
paz
lapa copa do rei e rainha
ae eu disse já voa e me disse volta eu
disse oh
ai que saudade de voz debaixo do meu
cobertor é que saudade de voz debaixo do
meu coberto
calma a sua segurança não leva nada eu
quero ser seu homem de fazer chamada
amar amar você até você se chamar me
amar morgan
o zezé é um homem de família mais amadas
dizem até nós e japão
o advogado
é assim eu quero de você você cuida aí
não desisto de você ir você de mim vamos
até o fim do namoro pra mim e cuidar bem
dela você não é conhecer melhor que ela
volte pra mim o que você ela você vai
cumprir
cuidar bem dela ela gosta que é pai no
cabelo dela foi por um triz mas fui
capaz ela sempre quis
aquela cara de quem diz eu tentei juntar
vocês dois
o destino deve está nos olhando
[Música]
decepcionado pena
pena
você foi a culpada de amor você acaba
você que destruiu a minha vida
[Aplausos]
sei que me machucar meu coração me fez
chorar me deixando um beco sem saída
estou em demora agora mas por favor não
implorar por que eu me não chora não
tenho carro não tenho teto e se ficar
comigo é quem gosta do meu moleque
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sem querer convencer o coração desculpa
meu amor não tive a intenção de falar
hoje desgaste dinheiro e fugir pois eu
não reagi ser amarelo e não estava ok
que a nossa festa eu te pegar de novo
hoje ninguém não me cada hoje pai que é
meu e eu quero ficar gostoso
hoje foi boa ideia mas falta de água
afeta o cérebro rn novo 10% derrete bull
10 do centro de água de coco
oitenta por centro esquerda efeitos é
tudo muito louco louco louco louco louco
louco louco louco louco louco eu sei com
108 logo logo
logo logo logo logo logo logo você nem
quis ouvir o que eu sentia
e é por isso que não
eu para dizer a você não entender
o que eu queria era tinha levado daqui
pra nunca mais sonhar a desistir é fé
pois fácil não é nem vai ser tentar até
se esgotar suas forças se eu já tenho
quero dividir orientar a esperança vai o
moço beijo no recalque passa longe
beijo no rosto ao caso e invejosos de
plantão pediu no resort fecha com um
bonde beijo no resort intensa exposição
dom dom 12 anos e já têm juntas on don
don don é só tem 12 anos e já tem jogo
de ontem
na verdade eu moro em um ano ter um
ponto de ônibus e 52 de goiaba né
aí um dia tinha um cinto estava morrendo
de fome eu fiquei pensando cara cabeça
será que eu pegue o certo eu vou pra
goiaba né
aí o governo era o bicho foi um golaço
por leite e água gigante estava morrendo
de fome
aí na hora que fui muito ea goiaba aí
chegou de maluca ali na frente fria
chega chega a irmã chega eu falei qual é
que foi agora a sua mão na minha
goiabada
vai complicar a morte de rodrigo já o
rio claro foi já era já era goiaba ele
morreu eu fui muito envergonhada
isso já é a galera
[Música]